SANDEEP PARIKH:
Welcome, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
I know the day's been
running a little bit long,
so I will hopefully
not keep you too long.
Welcome to the session
between you and happy hour.
Hopefully, we'll get you
out of here just in time
to get some drinks
and get some snacks.
My name is Sandeep Parikh.
I run the cloud
solutions architecture
team for Americas East,
for Google Cloud Platform,
and today, I want to talk
to you about building
a collaborative data platform.
Effectively, you've got
teams of individuals spread
across your company, that
have to work together
in some meaningful
way, and you need
them to share data,
talk to each other,
basically build
something together.
So, how do you enable that?
So, we're going to walk
through some of the ways
that we tell a lot of customers,
and developers, and partners
how to do that stuff
in the real world.
First, we're going to
meet our hypothetical team
of individuals, and
we're going to learn
about the tasks that have to
do, and the tools that they
typically use.
And then, we'll
jump into mapping
the tools they use to the tools
available in Google Cloud,
so you can start to
see how they might
get a consistent set of
tools and work together.
And then, we're going
to talk about how
we enable collaboration.
This is how we do
things, like set up teams
to do self-service and
easy data discovery.
I'm probably going to
trivialize a handful of details,
but stay with me, it'll make
sense as we get through it.
And then, I want to cover
what the new workflow's
like once you get all
this stuff up and running,
and then give you a
couple little things
and tips on how to get started.
Does that make
sense to everybody?
Head nods?
OK, good.
All right, so let's
meet the team.
All right, so first, we've
got about four individuals.
We've got a data scientist,
a data engineer, a business
analyst, and an app developer.
Ultimately, they all have
three things in common.
They use different data
sets, those data sets
are all in different
formats, and they all
use different tools, right?
So, there's not a
ton of overlap here,
and that's kind
of the challenge.
So, let's assume for a second,
or let's imagine for a second,
we've got this
team, and their job
is to build a recommendation
engine for a retail site.
So, what are the kinds of things
that each person on the team
is going to need
to be successful
in order to do their job?
So, the first thing
we'll cover is the data,
and then we'll talk
about the tools.
So, from a data perspective,
Alice, the data scientist,
needs kind of cleansed,
normalized data.
Things that have no
longer log files, right,
not just raw rows
from a database,
but things that
actually make sense.
And those could be,
for example, stuff
like purchase history, product
history, product metadata,
click streams, product reviews.
All the stuff that it would
take to actually craft and model
a recommendation problem.
Then, we've got Bob,
the data engineer.
He's going to have to
take all of the raw data
and turn it into
something useful.
So, he's probably going
to need things like,
logs information, product
transactions or purchase
history, product
metadata, as well.
This is all the stuff
that's coming in
straight off the
application, that he's
got to turn into something
useful for other parts
of the organization.
Then, there's Ned.
Ned is the business
analyst, and he
needs a lot of
aggregated data, things
that he can use to
generate statistics
and understanding about how
the business is performing.
Not just, again, rows
or log files, but again,
that next level up from,
sort of, the basics.
And then, finally, we have
Jan, the app developer.
She's going to need users
and product predictions,
or recommendations.
She's going to be
able to-- she needs
to be able to build
new microservices that
expose things like this
recommendation engine
to the end user.
So, that can be things
like a recommendations API,
access to wish lists, some
knowledge around similar users
or similar products, how
things complement each other.
But, you can see there's a
little bit of overlap here,
but not a ton, right.
They all need
something different
and they kind of need it in
a slightly different format.
Now, if you think
about sort of a--
I tried to draw a
sequence diagram here,
and it got a little
complicated, so I simplified it
a little bit.
But, ultimately, Alice and
Bob have to agree and talk
to each other.
Bob and Ned have to agree
and talk to each other.
Ned and Alice have
to talk each other,
and Jan and Alice have
to talk to each other.
You know, there's a lot of
communication happening.
And, listen, I love talking
to my coworkers just as much
as the next person,
but if you're
spending all of your time trying
to explain to them what you
need, when you need
it, where it came from,
what it should look like, it
becomes challenging, right.
It slows down the
ability for them
to make progress
and work quickly.
Ultimately, this is
the problem that we
see a lot of folks having
out in the, world, right?
They each have to
find data sets.
figure out who owns it.
They have to figure out
how things are related
to each other, and they have to
manage all that by themselves,
which, again, takes time away
from their ultimate task.
Just by a show of hands, does
this sound familiar to anybody?
Oh, that's a scary
number, actually.
Maybe I shouldn't have
asked that question.
No, but that this
is great, right?
This is how we have to-- we
have to find, understand,
what the problem is, then
try to solve it together.
All right, so let's
talk about tools.
That's the first step.
We need to understand
what everyone's
working with in order to
kind of make the next jump.
So, Alice is the data
scientist, huge fan of Python,
like myself.
It's like her Swiss
army knife, she uses it
for just about everything.
Typically, does
a lot of her work
with IPython or
Jupyter notebooks,
pulls data down, does
it on her workstation,
you know, slices
dices data, uses
a lot of pretty common
data science frameworks,
uses things like, NumPy,
SciPy, scikit-learn,
Pandas, because
she has a history,
and/or likes data frames.
That's a typical approach, from
a data science perspective.
Bob is a huge fan
of Java, right?
He does lots of big
ETL pipeline work,
does a lot of orchestrating
data from one format to another,
or multiple sources of data
together into something
that looks cohesive
on the other end.
So, he's typically using
tools like MapReduce or Spark.
In some cases, he might be
using Apache Beam, which
you'll actually hear more about
over the next couple days,
as well.
Ned is like a spreadsheet guy.
He loves SQL and he
loves spreadsheets.
So, what he likes to do
is build custom reports
and dashboards, very SQL-driven,
got to have some kind of access
to a data warehouse,
so he can do giant--
you know, kind of cube
rotations and understanding.
Basically, he's got to be
able to prove to the business
how products are performing,
why things like a recommendation
engine is even necessary.
So, it's his responsibility
to kind of facilitate that.
And then, we've got
Jan, the app developer.
Jan's a typical kind of
polyglot app developer.
Likes writing stuff on
microservices, likes delivering
features very quickly, you know,
may have a language preference
one way or the other, but has to
maintain a lot of the existing
infrastructure.
So, that could be
things like node apps.
That could be simple things like
Python apps with Flask or Ruby
apps with Sinatra,
all the way up
to like kitchen sink frameworks,
like Django or Rails.
Just depends, right,
whatever the use case is.
So, we've gotten that far.
So, we understand
their task, we know
who all the key players
are, and we know the things
that they like to use.
So, the next step
for us is, how do we
figure out which
tools they should
be using in Google Cloud?
All right, we can
skip that slide.
So, what we'll do
is let's lay out
a handful of the tools
that are available.
And we're not going to
cover everything that's
in GCP right now, because
we don't have enough time,
and I want you guys to have
snacks at some point soon.
So, what we'll do is kind of
focus on the core set of things
that are critical for each
of those individual roles
to have access to.
So, the first part, you know,
for things like applications,
we've got Compute.
So, with things
like virtual machine
or virtual instances
with Compute Engine,
manage Kubernetes clusters
with Container Engine,
or just kind of manage
container deployments,
or Docker container
deployments with App Engine.
It's a good place to start.
On the storage front,
cloud storage for objects,
Cloud SQL for relational data,
Cloud Datastore for, you know,
NoSQL, or
non-relational datasets,
and Cloud Bigtable
for wide column.
And then, on the
data and analytics,
are then the more
processing kind of side,
Dataproc for managed
Hadoop and Spark clusters,
Datalab for IPython
notebooks, BigQuery for kind
of an analytical data warehouse,
and data flow for running
managed Beam, Apache
Beam pipelines.
And then, the last column,
or the last kind of group,
is machine learning.
So we've got cloud
machine learning,
which is kind of running
TensorFlow models,
and running them
at scale, things
like the natural language API,
the speech API, or the vision
API.
As you start to
think about the team
that we just introduced,
and you start
looking at this sort of bucket
of tools, of this set of puzzle
pieces, you can start
to see where things
are going to kind
of fit together
There's a consistent
set of tools
here that we can map
back on to the team.
So let's walk through each
one of those individually,
really quickly.
So, for data science workloads,
Alice has a couple of options.
We already talked about the
fact that she's a fan of Python,
so that maps really well.
So, with Python,
she has two options.
She can either
use Cloud Datalab,
or she can use Cloud
Dataproc with Jupyter.
With Datalab, what she gets
is a complete Python dev
environment.
You know, it's bundled in with
like NumPy, SciPy, Matplotlib,
so she can kind of kick off her
work, and build those charts,
and build those, kind
of understanding,
or on the data set as she would.
Additionally, on
top of that though,
it's also got built-in support
for TensorFlow and BigQuery.
This means she's got a complete
environment to go and start
maybe prototyping
models that she wants
to build with
TensorFlow, if she's
trying to build a very
compelling recommendation
mechanism.
Or, if she needs data
that lives in BigQuery,
she can actually do inline SQL
statements there, and pull data
back out, or offload queries
to BigQuery, as well.
So, she's got a handful
of options there.
The nice thing about Datalab is
that it's based on Jupyter, so,
it's got a little
bit of background.
So, it should look
very familiar to her.
But it is somewhat
constrained onto just Python.
If she's got more
specific needs,
or wants to include additional
frameworks or kernels,
then we have to look at
something like Cloud Dataproc
plus Jupyter.
So, what you can do is you
can spin up a Cloud Dataproc
cluster--
again, a managed YARN
cluster, effectively--
and then have Jupyter
pre-installed on there
and ready to go.
So, it takes about 90 seconds
to fire up a Hadoop cluster,
anywhere from like
three, to like
a couple of thousand nodes.
In this case, for Alice, I think
just three nodes is probably
appropriate, and her goal is
to just spin this up and get
Jupyter pre-installed.
Once she's got
Jupyter, then she's
back to the exact
same environment
she had on her laptop, support
for over 80 different languages
and frameworks or kernels.
But, the nice thing
also is built-in support
for PySpark and Spark MLlib.
So, you know, if
you're kind of trying
to figure out where the machine
learning line sort of falls,
there's definitely a
handful of more sessions
you can attend around things
like TensorFlow or on Dataproc.
What I would urge you
to do is, if you've
got kind of an individual like
this in your organization,
is have them explore both.
TensorFlow might be appropriate.
Spark MLlib might
be appropriate.
And there should be
a clean distinction
between what they can each do.
All right, on the data
processing front, same thing.
Bob's got a couple
of different options.
He can either use Cloud Dataproc
or he can use Cloud Dataflow.
With Dataproc, again, we just
talked about this briefly,
but managed Hadoop
and Spark clusters,
the nice thing about Dataproc--
and I'm only going to
spend a minute on this,
so, by all means, if you're
interested we can do questions
afterwards-- but the
nice thing about Dataproc
is that it turns that kind of
mindset of a Hadoop cluster
or a YARN cluster, on its head.
You end up going away from
having a cluster-centric view
of the world, and turning it
into more of a job-centric view
of the world.
So instead of firing up
a thousand-node cluster
that everybody
shares, you could have
every individual job have their
own thousand-node cluster.
And as long as those jobs can
be done in less than 24 hours,
you can actually take
advantage of things
like preemptible OVMs or
preemptible instances.
Those instances are
about 80% off list price.
So, you get the ability to do
this job dramatically faster
than ever before, because you
have all this extra compute
sitting around, and you get
to do it really cheaply,
because it only takes
a few hours anyway.
So Bob's got that option.
He can also do things like
tune the cluster parameters,
or if he's got custom
JAR files he needs,
easily bootstrap those across
the cluster, doesn't matter.
So, h has that option.
The other approach
is to use Dataflow.
Dataflow is a managed
service that we
have for running
Apache Beam workloads.
Apache Beam is basically
a programming model,
or an approach, that
unifies batch and stream
processing into one.
When you take Beam
workloads or Beam pipelines
and you push them to Cloud
Dataflow, we run those for you
in a totally managed, kind of
automatically scalable fashion.
So, that's pretty nice.
And Apache Beam workload's
on Cloud Dataflow,
actually support
templates for kind
of like easy
parameterization and staging
and things like that.
The way I kind think about the
relationship here of which path
you go down is really
a question of what
do you have existing already.
If you've got a huge investment
in Spark or MapReduce jobs,
or just kind of like oozy
workflows around those things,
by all means, go down
to Cloud Dataproc group.
It's a turnkey solution.
You can take your job and
just push it to a new cluster,
just like that.
If it's net new and you're
starting from scratch,
I think Beam is a good
approach to look at.
It's relatively new, so
it's a little bit young.
It's definitely not as mature
as some of the other components
in the Hadoop ecosystem.
But, it does have
this really, really,
really critical advantage where
you can take a batch pipeline
and turn it into a
streaming pipeline
just by changing a
couple of lines of input.
So Bob's got a couple
of options here,
to kind of match up to what he
typically likes to work with.
All right, Ned's use case
is actually really simple.
He needs a data warehouse.
He needs a data warehouse
that supports SQL,
and that can scale with
whatever size of data he needs,
or that he's got
access to, and he's
got to be able to plug it
into a whole host of tools,
kind of downstream.
So, BigQuery's a
great fit for him,
enterprise cloud
analytical data warehouse.
It's a fully managed mechanism.
We often use the
word server-less,
though I hate that
term, so I apologize.
It supports standard
SQL and it does scale up
to a kind of petabyte scale.
So, he has the option of
running something that's
anywhere from data sets that are
about gigabytes all the way up
to petabytes, and still get
responses back within seconds.
BigQuery is great,
because it does
support kind of batch loading,
or streaming inserts, as well.
And it's got built in things
like security and durability
and automatic availability,
and all the other good stuff.
But, ultimately, the best part
is that Ned gets to use SQL,
gets to query really,
really large data sets,
and visualize and explore
the data as he's used to,
with the typical tools
and expertise he's got.
When it comes time to create
reports and dashboards
and things like that, there's
a couple of options he has.
One, he can use
Data Studio, which
is built into the platform.
So, it's kind of like a Google
Doc style approach, where
I can create a new
report, and then I
can share that with
everybody in the company
without actually having
to create multiple copies.
And people can edit
things like parameters
and watch the difference
in those reports,
and see how they look.
But effectively,
he has the ability
to create those
reports and dashboards.
Alternatively, he could use
things like Tableau or Looker,
or other business
intelligence tools
that he's that he's a fan of.
So, he's got a handful
of options there.
And the nice thing also is that
because of all this approach,
like BigQuery also
supports other kind of JDBC
infrastructure, so a lot of the
tooling that Ned is typically
used to can plug right
into BigQuery, as well.
So, the last one is Jan.
We talked about this earlier.
Jan likes to deploy and
scale microservices,
so she's got two
easy options there.
If she's really, really
focused on complex container
orchestration, writes them--
wants to deploy things that way,
Container Engine's a great fit.
It's based on open
sourced Kubernetes.
We've got built-in health
checking, monitoring, logging.
We've got a private
Container Registry,
or she can go down
the app engine route,
and just take her Docker
containers, and push them up,
and we'll auto-scale
them for her.
The good thing is that along
with kind of the same health
checking, monitoring,
and logging,
App Engine also includes
a built-in load balancer
up front, has
things like version
management, traffic
splitting, as well,
and automatic security scanning.
So, again, a couple
of options here
that kind of make sense for her.
So, that's right.
We're all done.
Everybody's got tools,
they can all work,
and everybody is off--
off to the races.
That's not true.
We've only just kind of
scratched the surface.
So, they all have a consistent
set of tools to work with,
but we actually haven't enabled
any of the collaboration bits
yet.
So, we still have to
figure out how to get them,
not only to work
together, but actually
to work in a way that
makes sense, and scales up.
Right.
Their team is four people today.
It could be eight, 12, 16,
you know, in a few weeks.
So, we've got to
come up with a better
approach to managing the data
that they need access to.
So, if you're trying to
enable collaboration,
there are a handful of
things you're really
going to think about.
The first is, you've
got to find consistency.
And it's not just consistency
in the tool set, right?
That's also important, but
you also need consistency
in terms of where do you
expect data to be coming from,
where do you expect data to
be used downstream, right?
That's really important.
If you can't agree
on the sources,
if you can't agree on what
the downstream workloads are,
it's hard to really
understand how
everybody should work together
and use the same set of tools.
The next thing you want to do,
is take a really good hard look
at all the data that you're
trying to get access to.
And this isn't true
for every piece
of data that lives in
your organization, right?
It might be things
that are focused
on certain sets of the
company, like certain teams,
or certain tasks, but
ultimately, you've
got to figure out where all
this data lives, and take
an inventory on it, right?
Take an inventory
on it, and make
sure it's in the right
storage medium for everyone
to use as time goes on.
The next thing you
want to do is come up
with an approach
around metadata, right?
This is pretty
simple, but if you're
trying to figure out
who owns a piece of data
or where it came from, what
other data sets it's related
to, what are some of the
types of data that are located
in this data set without
actually having to go query it,
that's a really
challenging problem to do,
when you think about having
hundreds or thousands
of individual pieces
of data spread out
across your infrastructure.
Then, you want to enable
discovery and self-service.
You want people to be able to go
find these things by themselves
and pull them down as
needed, without having to go,
again, spend all
that time arguing
with people about
formats, and availability,
and tooling, and worrying about
where you're going to store it,
as well.
And then the last
thing is security,
right Don't leave
that on the table.
It's certainly important to
understand security, and more
broadly, identity, right, to
make sure we're tracking access
to all these things.
All right, so how do
we start with this?
I throw this in there.
You have to kind of embrace
the concept of a data lake.
I'm not suggesting you
have to go build one.
I know it's a totally
loaded buzzword and term,
but you have to build--
you have to embrace the idea
of it, on some level, right?
And this is kind of
what I said earlier--
if you start at the
very bottom, you first
have to understand what are all
the sources of data I've got,
right?
At least get everybody
to agree in the room
where data is coming in
from, and what it looks like.
Once you do that, you want to
find some, again, consistency
on which tools are we
going to use to store data?
You're not going to
consume every single part
of the platform, right?
It doesn't make sense to
just use every service
because it's there.
Find the ones that make
the most sense for the data
that you've got.
And we'll go through
that a second, as well.
And the last thing is, what
are the use cases, right?
How is the data going to
get used over time, right?
It's important that you
understand what those use
cases are, because they're going
to drive back to the data--
or to the storage mediums.
And it's important to
pick the storage mediums,
because that's going to
depend pretty heavily
on how the data comes
in, where it comes from,
and what it looks like.
All right, so where
should data live, right?
We know the sources,
we know the workloads,
but what do we do
in the middle there?
How do we figure out
which places to put data?
So this is kind of a
simple decision tree.
And I'll go into a little bit
more depth on the next slide
as well.
But some of this you can
kind of simplify, right?
If it's really
structured data, you're
kind of down to two options.
Is it sort of OLTP data, or
is that OLAP data, right?
Is it transactional,
or is that analytical?
If it's transactional, Cloud
SQL's a great fit, right?
It's a typical relational
database, no frills,
does what it does, and
it does it really well.
On the analytical side,
you have BigQuery, right?
So it depends on
what the use case
is that's starting to drive
it-- not just the structure,
but with the use cases.
The next column
is semi-structure.
So, you've got something that
you might know the schema for,
but it could change.
It could adapt in flight.
People might be
deploying new mobile apps
somewhere that customers
are going to use.
They're going to
start capturing data
they weren't capturing before.
All those things are possible.
So, if you've got
semi-structured data,
then it's a question of, how
do I need to query that data?
Again, we're back to what
is the downstream use case?
If it's something where you need
to query in any possible field
that you write in, data
source is a good choice.
When you write a piece of
JSON to Cloud Datastore,
we automatically index
every key by default.
That's part of that JSON.
Now, you can turn that
off, if you want to,
or you can pick the keys you
want, but, ultimately, you
have the ability
to query anything
that you've written in there.
Whereas when you put
data in a Bigtable,
you're basically stuck
with trying to have
to query by the row key.
And that's actually
pretty powerful
for a lot of really
great use cases,
especially like time series
data or transactional data.
But it's not a great
fit, again, if you
want to try to query
some random column,
you know, somewhere buried
throughout the dataset.
And the last one is
object, images media,
that sort of thing, that just
go straight into cloud storage
so, it's a pretty
simple approach.
So, if you break
this out a little bit
and start getting in
a few more examples,
you kind of end up with a
chart that looks like this.
We just covered object storage
really quickly a second
ago great for binary data,
great for object data,
media, backups,
that sort of thing.
On the non-relational
side for Cloud Datastore,
it's really good for
hierarchical data.
Again, think of like
JSON as a good example
there, to fit in
there, obviously,
great on like
mobile applications,
that sort of thing.
On the Bigtable side, really,
really powerful system
for heavy reads and writes,
but you have the row key only,
as your only option.
There's a little
bit of filtering
you can apply
outbound on a query,
but really, it's
driven by the row key.
So you've got a very
specific workload
you can use at a Bigtable
on the relational side you
have two options.
And I mentioned-- and I
didn't mention Spanner yet,
and it's still a little
bit early on Spanner,
but I did want to put it
into context for kind of,
for everybody in the room.
Cloud SQL's great
for web frameworks.
Typical web applications
that you're going to build,
typical CRED
applications are great.
Spanner's really interesting.
It's new for us.
It's still early.
Spanner hasn't gone into
general availability quite yet,
but it's an interesting
thing to keep an eye on,
especially as people
are building kind
of global-facing applications,
where their customers could be
just about anywhere, and
having a mechanism that
has a globally distributed
SQL infrastructure is really
powerful.
So, it's something to keep
your eye on as you kind of make
more progress with GCP.
And the last one
is warehouse data.
Data warehouse, BigQuery, that's
the right place to put that.
So, this is where
it gets interesting.
You found the tools,
you found the sources,
and you found the workloads.
How do you continue on this
path of enabling self-service
and discovery?
So, you've taken
all the data sets.
We've taken inventory
of all of them.
They're all located
in the right places,
but there might be a lot of it.
So how do we enable
people to actually find
the things they're
looking for over time?
And this is where metadata
is really important,
because I think if you guys can
kind of guess where I'm going,
ultimately, what
we're going to do
is we're going to try
to build a catalog,
and that catalog is what's
going to drive everyone's usage
downstream, and everyone's
ability to work on their own.
So, in order to
build the catalog,
though, you've got
to agree on metadata.
And actually, as it
turns out, fortuitously,
or fortunately I should say, the
Google research team actually
just published an
interesting blog post
about facilitating discovery
of public data sets.
And in it they cover things
like ownership, provenance,
the type of data
that's located--
that's contained
within the data set.
They relationships
between various data sets,
can you get consistent
representations,
can you standardize some
of the descriptive tools
that we use to do it.
It's basically just JSON.
There's nothing
fancy about this,
but it forces everyone
to come up and say,
I have a consistent
representation
of every single data set.
So, you start to imagine, if
you have 100 data sets strewn
across the company, you're
only saying to everybody,
if you are an owner
of a data set,
just publish this
small little JSON file,
and hand it over
to us, and now we
can start cataloging this data.
That's really powerful.
What's even better is, if
you've got that JSON data,
we already had a
place to put it.
So, you have two options here.
You can either push that JSON
data into Cloud Datastore
or into BigQuery.
And I'll kind of cover
the difference here.
Cloud Datastores are a
great place for this data,
for a variety of reasons.
Again, JSON's really
well represented.
You can query about any
possible field there.
But the downside is, that
Datastore doesn't really have
kind of a good user-facing UI.
It's very much
application-centric.
So, if you want to go ahead
and build a little CRED
API on top of this thing,
Datastore can be a good fit.
The other option is,
frankly BigQuery.
You know, same idea around
Datastore and storing JSON,
in fact, this is an example of--
this screenshot as an example
of what this JSON
looks like in BigQuery,
because it does
support nested columns.
BigQuery is great because,
you've got a UI attached to it.
There's a console right
there, so you can actually
run SQL queries on it.
SQL's relatively universal
across a lot of folks.
They understand
it really easily.
So, this might make a
little bit more sense.
To be totally fair and
totally honest with you guys,
when I typically
recommend this approach,
I often will push
people to BigQuery,
as a place to build this
data catalog around,
because it just makes
sense, and it plugs
into a lot of downstream tools.
Datastore can make
sense, but it's
very, very particularly
dependent on how
the team wants to work.
For trying to find kind
of a good generic solution
to start with,
BigQuery's a great fit.
So, once you've done
that, you've pushed--
we've inventoried, we've
cataloged, we've got metadata,
and we've got everything
living inside of BigQuery now.
So, how does this
change the workflow?
I'm only going to pick on
one, because they're all
going to start looking a
little bit similar, if I
keep eating through it.
But, let's talk about the
data science workflow.
So, for Alice, now instead
of having to go talk to Bob,
or go talk to Ned,
or go talk to Jan,
or talk to anybody
else in the company
about what data is out
there that she can use,
the first thing she can do is
start to query the catalog.
So, she can just drop
into the BigQuery UI,
and run a simple SQL query,
and explore the data sets
that she has access to.
The next thing she can
do, because part of what's
in there, one of the pieces of
metadata, is what is the URL,
or what is the download
location for this,
she can go ahead and pull that
data into her environment.
Again, whether she's
running a Cloud Datalab
notebook, or a
Jupyter notebook, she
can pull that data
into her environment.
And then, she can start to
prototype a TensorFlow model,
for example.
She could start building a
little bit of a TensorFlow
model and running
some early analysis
of measuring how well her
recommendation engine might
be working.
Once she does that, she might
have created some new datasets.
She might have actually
taken something and said,
now I actually have
training data and test
data to work against.
So, now that she's
created two new datasets,
the next thing she's going to do
is upload those to the catalog.
Write the metadata,
push that in,
so now other people that might
want to build this stuff later
on, have access to the
same training and testing
that she used.
So, we're starting to create
this kind of lifecycle around.
Making sure that if you create
something new, make sure
it gets shared with everybody
as quickly as possible.
And then, she's going
to continue on her work
like she normally does.
She'll train her
machine-learning models.
She might push that
TensorFlow model
to, like, the cloud ML service.
And then, because the cloud
ML service that she created
is actually a data
kind of a resource,
she can actually create a
catalog entry for that service.
So, now if someone says, I
want to find a recommendation
service within the
catalog, as long as she's
tagged and labeled
everything appropriately,
they could find the URL for
that service immediately.
And this is a bit
of a simplification,
or oversimplification,
of the amount of work
it takes to do all this.
But, if you start to
extrapolate these steps out,
she's been able to
work at her own pace
without having to worry about
trying to find who owns what,
who has access to what she
has access to, because we've
built this data catalog.
We've built this
approach to metadata.
Over time, we're kind of
getting to this point where
we can start building
again toward self-service.
So, just like we have a
SQL-- a great SQL interface
for querying that
data catalog, you
might want to continue down
the self-service path and say,
can we make these things
even more discoverable?
Can we put like a CRED
API on top of this?
So, one option is to take a
small application or small CRED
API that sits in front of
this BigQuery metadata catalog
and deploy that in, like,
Compute Engine, or App
Engine, or Container
Engine, and front
it with, like, cloud endpoints.
The reason you might
go down this road
is particularly around
good API management,
and building-- again,
consistent and clear access.
Because the best way you can
enable sort of self-service
is, obviously, giving
everybody access to it,
but also giving
everybody access to
in a way that is most
beneficial to them.
So, if you've got a lot of
folks who are very API-driven,
or want to build
new applications all
the time, having an API
endpoint that they can
hit to learn more
about the data catalog
is very, very beneficial.
And over time, you
can actually start
to extrapolate this
step even further,
and start fronting all of
the data sources you've got.
So, not only do you have a CRED
API in front of the catalog,
but you might actually
have one in front
of every single dataset.
So now, again, you're enabling
this further, you know,
deeper level of access to data.
And this might be a
little bit overkill
for the team of four
people, but imagine
if that was a team
of 400 or 500 people.
As you think about
this kind of approach
permeating the
entire organization,
everyone wants to have
access, and you've
got to start building these
things for scale over time.
So, picking the right tools
up front lets you adopt that,
and again, lets new teams pick
this approach up, as well.
Before we finish this,
I do want to talk
a little bit about security,
early security and identity,
in kind of a broad sense.
We've got a great set of
identity and access management
tools called Cloud IAM.
There's a ton of
sessions about it
throughout the next
couple of days,
so I urge you guys, if you're
interested to go dig into it.
What I really want
to cover here though,
is this idea that there's
policy inheritance that
goes from the top all
the way to the bottom.
That means, at any level, if
you set a policy on data access
or control, it does
filter all the way down.
So, if you've got
an organization
or a single project
that's kind of the host
project in your project
account with GCP,
and you've got individual
projects for maybe dev
staging, Q&A, that sort
of thing, or production,
and then you have
individual resources
underneath those
projects, you can actually
control who has access to
what, as long as you've set
your organization up correctly.
I'm not going to
go too deep here,
but, basically, the
idea is to walk away
with is, we have the ability
to control who can see what,
and who can pull things
down, and that's really
what you want to control.
And, for example, if you dig
into BigQuery a little bit,
you've got a handful of roles
and different responsibilities,
or different access
controls that they've
got based on that stuff.
So, as you look at
what kind of what--
if you look at and
think about what it's
going to take to
build for the future,
I put the site up again, because
it's really important, if you
do nothing else, if
you build nothing else,
you have to get agreement.
That's the most important thing.
If you can't adopt
this idea that we
have to have consistency
around data sources, data
workloads, and then
the tools we're
going to use to
work with that data,
this is going to be a long road.
As much as I talk about the
products and the blue hexagons
and stuff, a lot of
this is a cultural shift
in an organization.
It's kind of a lifestyle change.
You have to get everybody
on the same page.
And part of doing that is
saying, can we add consistency?
Or can we make this a
consistent view of the world
that we can all agree upon?
And this might be a small
subset of what you end up with.
It could be a much, much larger
picture with a lot more pieces
to it, but it's important
that everybody agrees, again,
what the data is going
to look like coming in,
what it's going to get
use for on the way out,
and where it's going
to live while it's
sitting in your infrastructure.
As you think about--
as you kind of get through
that consistency piece--
and, you know,
that's a tough road,
but once you get through
that, then the next step
is really getting around to
some building the catalog.
Can you catalog
all the data sets?
Do you know exactly what lives
throughout the organization?
Can you get everyone
to kind of pony up
and say, all you have to do
is write this little snippet
of JSON, and we'll be
able to leave you alone
for the next few days.
If you can build the catalog,
that's a great first step.
Then the next thing
you want to do, is
make sure your teams have
access to the tools they
need to do this work.
And this is not just the
tools that are in GCP,
but it's also, like, the
API access, or the SQL
access to the datasets.
Can they get those things?
Have you set up identity
and understanding security
correctly, so that
everybody has access?
Because what you want
people to be able to do
is work on their own,
without having to go
bother anyone else.
If they can do
everything they need
to do without interacting
with somebody else,
then when they do interact, and
they go have lunch together,
it's a lot friendlier
conversation, as
opposed to arguing about
who has access to data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]